مجالات التنافس الصيني الامريكيه لا تنتهي
هذه المره اداه التجسس جديده قد تكون انت
من يمتلكها مع ملايين البشر حول العالم
ونتحدث هنا عن السيارات وتحديدا
الكهربائيه ذاتيه القياده القلق الامني
يحيى لوسيله نقل جديده ليس بجديد قبل قرن
تحديدا في عام 1913 صادر الجيش الفرنسي من
فضاء الاسد اربعه الالماني باريس امرت
بمصادره اي صور لمواقعها المحصنه اليوم
باتل امر اكثر تعقيدا بيانات عن مكالمات
السائق وتاريخ تصفحه الانترنت
لاحقا يمكن ان تستخدمها الشركه المصنعه
بعدها ظاهرها لتحسين اعوام الامن والسلامه
لكن في الباطن يمكن نقلها للخارج وهو ما
تخشاه واشنطن وايضا بكين والاخيره صنفت
الامر في 2017 كتهديدا للامن القومي سهوله
اختراقيه الشبكات الرابطه لهذا النوع من
السيارات هاجس اخر وحقيقه اثبتها العام
الماضي مبرمج الماني عمره 19 عاما سيطر
على اكثر من 20 سياره تسلا في عشر دول
مختلفه وقتها كان بامكانه تشغيل السيارات
وتعطيل انظمه الامن وتحميل جميع المعلومات
المتعلقه بموقع ومسار وتاريخ رحلات
السياره
تيك توك الى هواوي والجيل الخامس الى
المركبات ذاتيه القياده الصينيه او ما
يعرف بالفيز اجتياح غير مسبوق للصين
للاراضي الامريكيه الامر الذي استدعى على
رحاله الطوارئ من قبل بعض المشجعين
الامريكيين من امكانيه تهديد الامن القومي
الامريكي واعتبار هذه التقنيات الصينيه
بما ثابت حصان طرواده مصارعون امريكيون
قدموا مشاريع تشريعيه تحدوا من جمع
الشركات الصينيه معلومات حساسه عن البنيه
التحتيه الامريكيه بما في ذلك معلومات حول
المنشات الحكوميه العسكريه ونقلبها الى
بكينا بالاضافه الى تشريعه تحكم الامن
السيبراني للمركبات ذاتيه القياده
المصارعون الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون شددوا
على ضروره التصرف بسرعه لضمان عدم السماح
للمركبات ذاتيه القياده بان تصبح مصدرا
اخر للبيانات المستخدمه ضد المصلحه
الوطنيه للولايات المتحده من قبل الصين